Luffy's so good with his devil fruit
that it is basically the only Power that
he needs for the entire first half of
the story but then this happens and he
suddenly realizes that he needs top tier
hockey similar to the likes of Shanks or
even Roger so that he can actually
survive in the new world and then after
seeing how overpowered he becomes using
haki in the second half of the story I
just couldn't stop wondering how strong
Luffy could have been if he never ate
his devil fruit at all and instead had
trained only haki ever since he was a
kid and it's what most likely happened
all the way back when Luffy first got
his devil fruit because let's assume
that the redhead Pirates don't
completely lose track of I don't know
the single most valuable devil fruit in
the world and so when hungry child Luffy
is looking around for like a little
snack to eat Shanks actually keeps the
treasure box with the devil fruit out of
a small child's reach and even though
kid Luffy is desperate to see what's
inside that box Shanks says no so
goodbye stretchy Luffy but of course
that's not all that's going to be
different because even without his
rubber Powers he's still the impulsive
kid that we know and love so when he
insults those Bandits he's still going
to get captured taken out to sea and has
to be rescued by Shanks because even
though he can now swim yeah he's still
no match for this monstrous seeking
right here and so now we get the first
major twist because when they get back
to land Luffy suddenly has a ton of
questions about how Shanks actually
managed to scare away that Sea King now
since this version of Luffy doesn't have
his devil fruit Shanks actually decides
to show Luffy the very basics of haki so
that he can grow strong and protect
himself and of course I'm talking
specifically about Armament and
observation hockey here since Luffy
hasn't actually awakened his conquerors
hockey quite yet although I do guess
it's possible that Shanks could assume
that Luffy has conquerors because of his
dad and grandpa so he might even tell
Luffy about all three powers right out
of the gate however this is of course
where we run into our first major debate
because when Shanks is about to depart
in the original story he gives Luffy the
straw hat as a kind of symbol of his
belief in the young boy that he can also
become a strong pirate at least that's
what we always thought but there is also
the very real possibility that zhangs
only tried to inspire Luffy in the first
place because he ate this particular
devil fruit and that's of course because
Luffy's devil fruit is extra special and
we can only assume it is required in
order to actually become Joy boy and
find the one piece which Luffy just
managed to achieve in wano way later in
the story and so
Shanks still give up his hat if Luffy
doesn't have this devil fruit and I'm
honestly not quite sure but I do like to
think that Luffy's personality would
still Inspire Shanks plus it is still
possible for Luffy to find love tale and
become pirate king technically without
becoming Joy boy I mean Roger did it so
let's just assume that Luffy still does
get the hat and Shanks even tells him
that he might even tell him more about
what was in that treasure chest when
Luffy actually comes back and becomes a
great pirate which now leaves us with
the absolute crazy scenario of Luffy
growing up training his hockey instead
of his devil fruit Powers I mean can you
just imagine him running around the Goa
Kingdom blasting off hockey punches he
would be insanely strong and I honestly
think that his grandfather Garb would
actually be quite happy to see his
grandson learning hockey so early that
he might even decide to train Luffy
personally occasionally which ultimately
means that Luffy's fighting style will
be quite similar to that of garb's where
he mainly fights with his fists which I
mean Luffy does even with his rubber
Powers anyways although I do Suppose
there is technically still a chance that
Luffy would eventually learn to use a
weapon since most haki only powerhouses
like Roger or Shang still use a weapon
as well but then again GARP here doesn't
but in fact I actually think I have the
perfect weapon for hockey Luffy to use
which we'll discuss a little bit later
on but first Luffy would probably also
awaken his conqueres hockey during this
time growing up perhaps that time where
he was captured by the bandits or maybe
even when Sabo died which means that by
the time that Luffy's ready to start his
pirate Adventure his hockey Stills have
leveled up from kind of noob to at least
Advanced if not already master and he's
basically at the same level that he was
right after the time skip but we'll see
very soon just how long he can actually
survive without his devil fruit and what
you may not even realize though is that
not having a devil fruit is actually
going to save his life more than once in
the East blue because While most of the
enemies in this part of the story were
fairly easy to beat yes you may have
forgotten that rubber Luffy almost
drowned twice once he was thrown off the
baratier and once when he dropped into
the water like an anchor while fighting
Arlon and so yeah both times he actually
had to be saved by others but that is no
longer a problem at all because this
version of Luffy has no restrictions
with swimming so defeating his enemies
becomes a simple problem of smashing
their faces with his hockey covered
kicks and I guess punches as well plus I
mean his observation hockey will help
him Dodge attacks pretty easily like for
example arlong spinning torpedo I mean
he would even be able to probably break
weapons using his hockey infused attacks
as well but of course the maybe most
insane part of Luffy's new abilities is
that he would definitely be able to
overcome his very first defeat against
the lokia food using Captain smoker
because if you remember Luffy only
really struggled against opponents who
actually had a logia type devil fruit
because I mean he could simply not hit
them without either knowing their
Elemental weakness or yeah having hockey
but that's literally not a problem at
this point in time because once Luffy
figures out his hockey punches can
actually hit smoker I don't think there
is any way that the Marine Captain will
be able to defeat Luffy which when you
think about it might mean that his very
first hockey might actually end up being
a way higher heading into the grand line
which might actually be a serious
problem a little bit later on but at
this point I also think that we should
mention that if Luffy knows so much
about hockey he most likely would also
teach other members of the crew what he
knows about hockey although let's be
honest he's probably not the greatest
teacher and he might just tell them to
figure it out on their own kind of
giving them like a rough explanation but
being around Luffy himself and seeing
him use hockey abilities could mean that
characters especially like Zorro and
Sanji do figure out how to use haki much
much earlier in the story and as a
result a much needed early major power
boost for the entire crew which of
course takes us straight through the
alabaster Saga to the eventual clash
with the warlord crocodile and now in
the original story Luffy had to fight
crocodile not once not twice three times
and there's no doubt that he would have
died each time if it weren't for help
from either other people and also a ton
of luck but once again hockey is just
going to completely change these fights
because the ability to actually hit
logia fruit users is just so overpowered
that Luffy should be able to deal heavy
damage to crocodile basically right away
however that isn't to say that this
fight would be super easy especially
since Luffy can only basically attack
from close range since he can stretch
his body but then again crocodile might
also just be super surprised to find
someone in this part of the world who
can already use hockey so really there's
no doubt in my mind that hockey Luffy
would find a way to win and save his
friend vivi's Kingdom okay so far so
good for hockey Luffy but let's see if
he can actually survive against the
strongest characters like the one coming
up next and that's because things are
about to get impossibly difficult when
the crew flies up to skypia because it's
here of course that they come face to
face with the Lightning God NL and Luffy
is going to need a massive power boost
to actually take him down so let me
explain why in case you forgot the only
way that Luffy was actually originally
able to defeat NL who was a crazily
overpowered fruit user was because of
his rubber body's natural immunity to
electricity in other words nl's insane
main attacks were basically useless but
that Advantage is now completely out of
the window so at this point Luffy is in
quite serious danger of Getting
one-shotted By this electrical
Powerhouse and yes just like with
crocodile Luffy can easily damage the
logia fruit user with his high lucky but
the problem is actually getting close
enough to anal to do so because I mean
it doesn't matter how hard you punch if
you get your heart fried before you ever
get close enough to actually attack but
then again skypia also might be the
perfect opportunity to introduce two new
power ups for hockey Luffy because one
thing that we know for sure about Luffy
is that he's basically a hockey Prodigy
which means that he is extremely good at
learning the basic and Advanced
Techniques of hockey so I do think after
pushing his observation hockey too like
the absolute Max when dodging announce
lightning bolts it's quite realistic for
him to actually awaken Advanced
observation hockey during this fight and
doing so would let him see a few seconds
into the future and give him a huge
Advantage dodging attacks and kind of
getting close to anal but if that still
isn't enough Luffy also gains another
huge bonus by not being a devil fruit
user and that's because in the original
story we already saw that this shandyan
Warrior uses C prism stone to help him
nearly kill Eno and normally see prison
Stone drains the power of any devil
fruit user but now that Luffy is devil
fruit free he could also somehow use
these stones to gain an advantage
against NL I mean really I can just
imagine usop somehow making him some sea
prison Stone brass knuckles or something
so that his punches would be extra
damaging to any devil fruit user which
let's be real is almost every single one
of Luffy's fight so with all of this put
together hockey Luffy with his knuckles
should be able to take down NL and save
skypier somehow but of course all of
that is not actually going to be enough
to save haki Luffy from being completely
overwhelmed by April aokiji I mean even
in the original story he was just
completely Washed by the Admirals ice
Logan powers and even though hockey
Luffy in theory will probably land a few
blows still don't think that he even
comes close to having a chance to win
this fight but we'll see if that's still
the case the next time that Luffy
actually fights an admiral in basically
just a minute however while they
eventually survived that encounter with
the first Admiral Luffy's missing devil
food will play a major role in the
outcome of this next battle because
after Robin was kidnapped by the world
government secret agents from cp9 Luffy
needed not one but two massive power-ups
to defeat the leopard man rob Lucci
those of course would be Gear 2 which
gave him an incredible boost in strength
and speed plus Gear 3 which allowed
Luffy to increase the size of his fists
but again these upgrades are completely
gone now so what is Luffy going to do
now well there are a few options I think
that could work here first hockey Luffy
could just be so stupidly overpowered at
this point that he beats Luffy even
without needing any upgrades at all and
honestly I think that is actually
perfectly valid but if in some case that
doesn't satisfy you then we can also
consider that the entire crew is
probably way stronger from seeing
Luffy's Hawking action so perhaps Zorro
and Sanji also defeat their opponents
much faster and easier and they can all
team up to kind of fight with their
captain and take down Luchi and so
either way I think it should be easier
than ever for the crew to free Robin
Escape Luffy's grandfather GARP and then
just Breeze through Thriller bark let's
be real to reach Saba ODI however this
is where things are actually going to go
absolutely crazy and it all starts by
you hitting that nice red subscribe
button for more one-piece content just
like this but here in sabaori is
actually where hockey Luffy will truly
be tested for the very first time and we
could assume that Luffy's Advanced
observation hockey will actually help
him make sure that this mermaid never
gets kidnapped in the first place
however that still takes a lot of fun
out of this Arc so let's just imagine
that Luffy's still somehow punches a
world Noble which still means that
Admiral kizaru and the Cyber about
classifista still come to hunt them down
so here is I think where hockey Luffy is
really going to shine because if we
assume that he's actually starting his
journey with hockey skills as good as
right after the time skip then he should
be able to crush the Posse fista no
problem right I mean just look at what
he did to this one before they left for
Fishman Island plus he's grown stronger
through all of his fights so honestly
don't really see the possifist as being
all that big of a problem for any of the
straw hats really which does mean that
we have to ask if they would still need
to be separated by the warlord
Bartholomew humor I mean I do think that
Luffy at this point might put up a way
better fight against kizaru but he still
wouldn't be able to take him down alone
I mean just read the Manga right now so
if Rayleigh is there to hold off the
Admiral there is a pretty great chance
that the crew would Escape together
somehow on the other hand if Kula was
really determined to send them all off
across the world there there is really
nothing that Luffy could do about it at
all at this point I mean hockey isn't
going to stop the awesome powers of
Kuma's pushes plus they wouldn't be able
to go to fisherman Island quite yet
without having a coated ship so let's
imagine that the story kind of follows
the normal path and they all still get
separated like they used to and Hell
before we see the huge impact that
Luffy's actually going to make at Marine
for it we first have to look at his path
getting to the Epic War which would go
pretty similarly to the original I think
although on the island of women the
pirate Empress Boa Hancock might fall in
love right from the start because of
Luffy's overwhelming conquerors hockey
and of course kindness but impul down on
the other hand wouldn't change all that
much he still wouldn't be able to punch
the venomous warden so no big changes
here I think however when Luffy finally
does drop into Marine for it I could
definitely see him actually charging
straight into the war with his full
conquerors hockey blazing and uh can you
just imagine that Insanity of an entire
battlefield of Marines and Pirates
turning to see this madman dropping down
from the sky a bunch of the weaker
enemies would probably just drop
unconscious on the spot and it might
even Force an admiral to come after
Luffy right away because he's an unknown
threat at this point and speaking of the
Admirals they are honestly some of the
few characters who can actually stop
hockey Luffy at this point I mean them
plus GARP and the fleet Admiral singoku
or the world's strongest swordsman
mihawk of course are truly their only
hope at this point because honestly even
someone like doflamingo I don't really
think could stop this level of hockey
Luffy with his current power level so
Luffy would definitely square off with
someone like kizaruba instead of being
easily sniped like in the original War
Luffy would put up a more than decent
fight at this point because of his
Advanced observation and the fact that
he can actually hit the light logia
fruit user which as a result might mean
that the Whitebeard Pirates actually
stand a way better chance of succeeding
in rescuing Ace because if Luffy is
taking the attention off of an admiral
all by himself that means that the
strongest Ally Pirates like the emperor
Whitebeard Marco the Phoenix and the
escaped prisoners like crocodile and
jimbei would get much much closer to
actually rescuing Ace but sadly just
because Luffy is way stronger that
doesn't really mean that he's strong
enough to win a one-on-one with an
actual Admiral so let's imagine that he
gets away and freeze A's just like in
the original story oh hold on wait that
that just means we're gonna head
straight to uh donut Ace again right
aren't we let's find out because with
the Luffy's Advanced observation hockey
he now should be able to actually sense
Admiral akinu coming and add at least
Dodge his fiery magnifice but he
honestly wouldn't be able to actually
run away forever and even if he is able
to block a magma Punch Hero there than
it would most likely just sent him
flying all across the battlefield and
then with Whitebeard still suffering his
normal heart attack that unfortunately
leaves Ace to once again getting fist I
mean killed by a kainu
almost Ace you got so close this time so
with the major turning point once again
over let's assume that Shanks once again
arrives stops the war and Luffy escapes
like normal maybe I mean I guess he
would still be knocked out from the
shock so I guess that doesn't change at
all either which gives us one major
question to ask would there still be the
need for a Time skip in this scenario
because if you remember Rayleigh came to
train Luffy with the main goal of
teaching him hockey but since Luffy
already is well on his way to being a
true hockey Master is that even still
necessary well honestly yeah I mean in
our version of the story the rest of the
crew is still very much separated and
they could definitely use time to train
plus I do think it would still be a huge
waste for Luffy to not train with one of
the few legitimate hockey Masters in the
world so let's assume that Rayleigh does
train Luffy for the normal time skip but
instead of learning basic hockey
Rayleigh puts him through a brutal
training regiment that actually helps
him master all advanced armament and
possibly also Advance conkress even
especially after everything he
experienced during the war although I
must admit that Luffy probably wouldn't
Master this last one quite yet fully
because as we know haki truly blooms
mostly during intense battle however all
of this means that after time skip
hockey Luffy and the straw hats are way
way more overpowered for the rest of the
new world and honestly I could just see
this version of Luffy one-shotting and
soloing the Post Time skip opponents
like the roided up Fishman this gas man
and even though Flamingo which basically
just leaves Luffy to fight against the
emperor's big mom and kaido and during
the whole kick island arc we could get
one of the most interesting clashes
against big mom's strongest son katakuri
because for much of the original
katakuri didn't really respect Luffy as
a fighter and for very good reasons
katakuri was clearly stronger with his
Superior Armament hockey and future side
hockey but in this version of the story
there is no doubt at all that Luffy has
the upper hand and so I would actually
wonder if katakuri would even go as far
as to fight Luffy directly or would they
even Clash at all I mean Luffy might
just be able to kick him off the ship
which would allow the crew to just Coop
the burst away from the sunny also Luffy
might end up having a way longer clash
with big mom during this Arc but since
his original goal was just go in rescue
Sanji and go out I don't really think
that they just like have an all-out
Clash at this point quite yet so on to
wanokuni and the biggest controversy yet
maybe because this is the scene of
Luffy's highest test so far against the
strongest creature in the world kaido
and honestly I'm gonna drop a hot take
here because if Luffy is facing kaido
while already having a ton of XP
variants with Advanced Armament hockey
future side and he understands the basic
of advanced conquerors then I truly
don't see how kaido can beat our Luffy
here because Luffy was beat down so so
much during his original fight with
kaido and it wasn't until he actually
learned Advanced conquerors that he was
able to actually do any real damage to
the king of the Beast and although Luffy
even had to awaken gear 5 to eventually
beat the Oni dragon by this point he was
already super exhausted so if Luffy has
basically his strongest abilities from
the very start of the battle I mean
maybe even right after coming to wano
then I think his insane willpower
durability and overall hockey Mastery
will just lead him to defeat kaido once
and for all way easier and faster than
before but and this is a big butt that
leaves us with a super important
question because without unlocking gear
5 can Luffy still become joyboy and
bring freedom to the world well honestly
I think no I mean it was pretty clear in
the original story that it was only
after Luffy awakened his devil fruit and
gear 5 that this giant elephant
officially recognized him as Joy boy so
without his legendary Nikka devil fruit
it just isn't possible I think but
remember that little promise that Shanks
made to Luffy at the start of this video
let's discuss that more in just a moment
because from here I think Luffy has a
pretty clear even path to finding love
tale and becoming pirate king and we do
know that he doesn't need to be Joy boy
to find love tail since Roger was
technically able to do it so the
question would be could Luffy still use
whatever treasure was left at love tale
to go on to save the world without
actually being Joy boy where we're not
100 sure but this could also be the
perfect time for Luffy and Shanks to
meet up and if Shanks has been holding
on to the Nika fruit all this time then
he could very well offer to Luffy right
now if he truly believes Luffy to be the
right person to become Joy boy and while
I don't even know if hockey Luffy at
this point would all of a sudden even
want to eat a devil fruit and even if he
did it might take him some time to
awaken it but if this is a required step
to save the world I could see Luffy
ending up doing it or who knows maybe he
just eats It Again by accident which you
know might be a little bit disappointing
since he came all this way with Just
Hockey but since he's already eating one
devil fruit why don't we even make it a
little bit more crazy by giving him a
second devil fruit as well which yep
sounds completely wild but can you
imagine if Luffy had two devil fruits at
the start of the story so if you want to
know which Powers would best combine
with his original Fruit and how it would
completely change his Adventure you can
watch that video right here thank you
very much to main grader 4434 who
suggested this video if you have any
cool ideas for any what ifs feel free to
drop them in the comments and uh yeah
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one